Hi. In this video, we'll look at how you can use Burp to manipulate WebSocket messages.
Finding vulnerabilities in WebSockets generally involves manipulating messages in ways that the
application doesn't expect. For example, if you can modify existing messages or create new ones,
you may be able to deliver SQL injection or cross-site scripting exploits. We can use
Burp Repeater to modify and resend WebSocket messages. If you'd like to follow along with
the steps, you can use the Manipulating WebSocket messages to exploit vulnerabilities lab from our
Web Security Academy. Once the lab has launched and you've browsed around the target application
to map the attack surface, go to Burps Proxy WebSocket's History tab. This tab displays a table of any
WebSocket messages that Burps browser has exchanged with the target host. And here we can see the
messages from the live chat in the lab. Right-click a message that you want to resend or modify,
for example one of the outbound chat messages, and click Send to Repeater. Burp will create a new
WebSocket tab in Repeater. Go to the Repeater tab and click Send in the new tab. You can check the
History panel to confirm the message was resend. In the Send WebSocket message panel, you can now modify the
message. For example, you could send a proof of concept XSS attack at this point. Click Send again.
When you check the History panel, you can confirm the modified message appears as sent.
You can confirm the message appears as sent. You can confirm the message appears as sent.
You can confirm the message appears as sent. You can confirm the message appears as sent. You can confirm the message appears as sent.